>>Male Presenter: What does organic mean anymore?
Tales from the front lines of the movement
and just to give you a little bit of background
on who Bob Scowcroft is is basically he's
an activist.
He first joined the environmental movement
to work on the Alaskan Native Claims Settlement
Act in the early 1970s and later became a
national organizer on pesticide issues for
the Friends of the Earth.
As organizer for the FOE, he set up table
at the Natural Food's Agent Orange because
of the drift of that herbicide on nearby farms.
And basically from there, um, Barney Brickman
and 2 other organizers from the California
certified organic farmers came and paid him
a visit to his table and introduced Scowcroft
to the organi, organic farming movement and
since then he became the first professional
environmentalist to attend and present at
the ecological farming conference.
Then held at a muddy church camp in the Santa
Cruz Mountains.
>>Presenter 2: Hi everyone, I'm Liv and I'm
a chef.
And I'm just delighted to have my friend Bob
here.
I met him at the EcoFarmConference.
So, 15 years after I interviewed him as a
reporter when I was in Chicago, so thank you
for coming.
>>Bob Scowcroft: You're welcome.
>>Presenter 2: Bob is quite a story teller
and raconteur so I'm, we're just gonna be
pretend it's not summer and it's winter.
We've got our feet pulled up to the fire and
I'm just gonna ask a few questions and I think
he'll just go.
So, that was a long time ago.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Yes, that video was shot
it 1989.
He noted that organic was about 1 percent
of the food economy.
We are 23 years later and thousands of articles
and reporters and chefs, organic's now 4 percent
of the economy.
When I joined CCOF I was the first full time
employee and director, there were 178 farmers
in the program.
When I left there were 780 farmers in the
program.
During the 5 years that I was at CCOF, actually
I'm just gonna step back and say, to give
you a sense of the history of organic, it
started to be written about in the 20s and
30s, both in Japan and in the UK.
Rodale really brought it to the US in 1947,
first publication of Organic Gardening.
But, Mokichi Okada in Japan and Sir Albert
Howard and Lady Balfour, Lady Balfour is the
key, you know, royalty is what it is; she
was interested about the soils so she started
a soil association in the 20s over there in
the UK.
So this, to this day we hear that it's a fad.
Well, we're getting on almost 100 years, 80-90
years; I think the fad part a really mute
point now.
But the first regulation was written in Oregon
in 1974.
The first law, actual law, was in California
in 1978; it was a 2 page law and Ag so disliked
the word organic that the only way they could
get it passed was to make into the health
and nutrition program.
I'm not sure if you knew that.
And California health and safety code was
where the first organic food act was parked
and it had no enforcement, it was 2 pages
long but it did define the simplistic no synthetic
devotion to natural crop rotation; the very
basics of what organic had started out.
So by '89 with Alar, which was, to this day
they call it the Alar scare.
I very strongly point out it was not a scare,
it was carcinogenic and it was taken off the
market 6 months after CBS' 60 Minutes did
the story on it.
But it took Meryl Streep to bring attention
to it.
Environmentalists had been working on it for
a decade but it was Meryl Streep in the, on
a couple of TV talk shows, the power of talk
shows, that brought it to attention.
So, CCOF rewrote the California law for enforcement
and then a year later, thanks to Senator Leahy,
7 people got together and said we've written
the California law, we have friends in Oregon,
we have friends in New England, a couple in
Ohio, let's write a national law.
Little did we know what we were getting into.
But, for the power of individual and the power
of very small group, I think this is a particularly
critical story to tell.
That to this day, 7 to 10 people dedicated
and with a vision can get together and can
make global change.
Never forget that.
It's happened here.
It happens in a lot of places.
>>Presenter 2: So that was 1 percent of the
market.
We're now at 4 percent?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Little over 4, 4.2, 4.3
>>Presenter 2: So I'm gonna ask the question
from the other side.
Why so slow?
Why so, what's, what have been the impediments?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Um, uh, absolute to this
day, resistance from the agro industrial food
system and it's an integrated system, crop
insurance; you can't get organic crop insurance
to organic research; you can't get that to
scale.
Now there's 4 supermarkets and 3 box stores
that represent something like 70, 7 buyers
in United States purchase between 70 and 80
percent of all our food.
7 buyers.
>>male #1: All food or organic?
>>Bob Scowcroft: All food total comes through
7 buyers.
Now, it's like, in California there are 2,200
organic farms, 2 of them, and I said earlier
in a meeting I'm gonna try not to use brand
names, but 2 of them gross a billion dollars.
And they sell into those 7.
So economies of scale, very difficult for
organic to integrate into, um, research, organic
pest management.
The system of Ag research is really product
based.
Actually, there was a law, this is a kind
of funny, well, depends on your Ag sense of
humor, Birch Bayh and Bob Dole wrote a law
in the 80s called the" Bayh Dole Act"
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: It's not, everyone's gonna
have pineapples but the "Bayh Dole Act" reformatted
the entire research system to be product based.
That you could be a company and give money
into an Ag research program and dedicate a
research question you have and you could profit,
i.e. patent, off that product that came out
with academia.
So, organic is information based.
You can't really patent information.
You can't, it's public domain activity.
So, finding out when to release the ladybugs
or when to apply, when to harvest a cover
crop, which cover crop works with which soil?
That was a historic Ag research program from
our land grant system, from the late 1890s
to the 1940s, that's what land grants did.
And then in, after the agricultural chemicals
became very popular in the '70s, by the '80s
the system, we wanted to cut funding for Government
waste and to Ag, we were wasting Government
money to get information.
So, instead, we wanted, by this act, to privatize
our Ag research system.
So imagine how you're gonna get an organic
crop rotation system in place.
I'd say that's very expensive, that's been
one of the main challenges is breaking that,
and the other part is also economy of scale,
competitive price organic can be is very expensive
in many parts of the country, you can't get
it year round in many parts of the country.
So the first person with berries or some of
the other fruits and vegetables sell it for
a lot of money.
That's something called the capitalist system
where they make a very healthy profit.
And, somehow, this is supposed to be, this
is supposed to be a negative to organic.
Well, it's, uh, buyer and seller working it
out.
Now, things have changed a little bit.
After CCOF, 2 farmers and I decided, talk
about tilting against windmills, we decided
that we were gonna change the grant making
program so we founded the Organic Farming
Research Foundation so that we could make
grants but our grants were based on, uh, agreeing,
upon receipt of money to not patent any information
that it was all, 100 percent, in the public
domain and that we would fund ideas as well
as actual projects.
And OFRF, I retired a year and a half ago,
I was the executive director for 20 years,
the average lifespan of a, professional lifespan
of an E.D. is 3 to 5 years.
So I was there 20 years and we made over 350
grants and many of those recipients are now
professors and are now, finally, over 20 universities
have organic research programs.
So, look how long it took us to get there.
>>Presenter 2: What was the most difficult
part about getting the federal law written?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Um, well, it's the opposition
of the agricultural industry; some of you
may have a little bit of awareness that the
Farm Bill is front and center this summer.
It's a really big deal.
Well, in 1990 was an earlier Farm Bill, the
House Agriculture Committee refused to hold
any hearings on organic.
I was actually in a meeting in the mid '80s
in the USDA that a senior agency official
came in and broke up the meeting 'cause a
communist sympathizer was there; that was
me.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Supporting organic family
farmers and I had to leave the building.
That's the intensity of the passion at that
period of time.
But, 1990, 5 years later, the House Ag Committee
refused to hold hearings so we actually had
one congressman from Oregon, two actually
with Sam Farr, but really, Peter Defazio carried
the bill on the floor of the house, no hearings,
no public testimony, no public comment.
Senator Cranston and Senator Leahy carried
it in the Senate.
One hearing, one time and on the house it
was voted 198 to 189 and we won the amendment
on the floor of the House.
And we just pushed every grass roots button
we had and the law was 16 pages long and it
required a National Organic Standards Board
which was the only advisory board that had
the right to stop a bad action and to recommend
a good action.
There are 29 advisory boards in the USDA,
only one has statutory power and that's the
National Organic Standards Board.
The administration at the time, and I have
to say including into the Clinton administration,
never empowered the actual drafting of the
regulations.
They were due 18 months after the passage
of the law; we got it 10 years.
It took them 10 years to post the rules and
they were terrible.
They suggested you could use genetic engineering;
you could put sewage sludge on organic farms
as long as –, a number of pasture regulations
were terrible.
They made a mistake, and actually this is
kind of a cool little computer story, it was
the first rule ever published on the internet,
it was the USDA decided, they had this little
corner thing, organic, no big deal and they
would publish it on the internet and ask for
public testimony, the largest testimony they'd
ever received was animal welfare issues around
production of veal which is a pretty lousy
way to, well we'll leave that for another
topic, but that had gotten 35,000 letters.
So they published the organic rules thinking
they'd get maybe a couple of thousand, we
generated 325,000 responses.
Working assets, now called CREDO Phone Company,
the largest single, it donated, it generated
35,000 comments through their phone subscriber
base, into the rules.
That was such a tsunami, ten times the comments
they'd ever received, that they had to rewrite
the rules and then the press, I think we we're
probably in contact, Liv and I and many others,
the press really caught wind of this major
embarrassment and made major organic hay about
it and they went back and had to rewrite them
again.
And, finally, in 2002, 580 pages of every
single thing you can and can't do around organic
was published and approved with two exceptions.
One was pasture, they didn't quite know how
to figure out what organic pasture and organic
meat and dairy was and is.
They just published the final rule there in
2010, 20 years later, and the other was the
interface between recombinant DNA, genetically
engineered products and organic.
All they said was you can't use it and we
felt there was a lot of protocol behind pollution
from that and some other issues.
So, those of you that wanna get into organic,
you gotta start when you're 20 or 30 cause
you're gonna take it from 4 percent to 50
percent you gotta be young, I think, well
maybe I'll be on a roll for a couple more
years.
>>Presenter 2: Really?
Can we reach 50 percent?
That would be astonishing.
>>Bob Scowcroft: You know, I think the infrastructure
as immature as it is, has the capacity to
do that understanding that organic transition
requires, one of the key threads is 3 years
from the last application of a prohibited
material.
So, if something happened and we had to go
organic, I believe essentially the body of
knowledge is there in almost every crop and
commodity to farm it organically but the land
isn't.
And we don't want sod busted or marginal land
or wets lands taken out and farmed organically.
We want the deep soil of the heartland farmed
that way but it's gonna take years, so I have
a fear, it's been my experience that organic
in many cases has grown due to sensational
pesticide stories for the most part, horrific
poisonings, drift, discovery or final proof
of carcinogenic chemicals and people throw
up their hands, "That's it, I'm gonna buy
organic.
I don't care."
So if we have some other more food safety,
food issue, stories coming down the pike the
push for organic with that same peaks and
valleys that we had during Alar where apples
went for 70 dollars a box that were 6 or 8
dollars a box, the size of that package before.
I will say, going a little bit out on a limb
here, my sense is that relative to food issues
and the things that I follow, that some of
the next frightening data that's just starting
to be peer reviewed, when I say frightening
it's not somebody standing up on a screen
and ruining a dinner party or in a public
speech, I'm talking about peer review science
coming out of Academia, the abuse of antibiotics
and chemicals in our meat production should
gray the hair on the back of everyone's head.
And the stories are just beginning to come
out.
Just recently, uh, and I can provide the link
later on if you wish, urine tract infections,
there's dinner party topic for ya
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: had been tied to a certain
antibiotic overused in poultry production.
They know this, medical schools have now proven
this and, yet, can we get that antibiotic
out of poultry?
They don't even, they want more research,
let's take, you know, the data's not really
in yet.
You know science; we need more studies in
the future.
Far as I'm concerned that data's in and what
I've read about some of the chemicals, antibiotics
in hog production, I only eat, I mean, I know
the meat I eat almost personally, not the
chicken itself
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: but the producer that made
it.
How do we transition, I guess is the, to get
the 50 percent, you need a government objective,
you need a massive investment in research
and, of course, you need the consumer that's
gonna be paying those higher prices, in some
cases, some seasons, to support it.
>>Presenter 2: We're close to 50 percent with
the Google culinary purchasing team with organic
>>Bob Scowcroft: Awesome, awesome.
>>Presenter 2: we're not quite there but,
and our meats and poultry are antibiotic and
steroid free and, but what's the positive
argument about organics?
Yes we want to avoid this and this but in
our culture where we're concerned about nutrition
and optimizing your life and things like that,
is there a benefit to eating organic that
is, say, something about nutrient density?
>>Bob Scowcroft: That's the, uh, that's the
Pandora's Box and I'm happy to open it.
>>Presenter 2: Go ahead.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: But I'm gonna ask you to
hold it for just about 60 seconds until, I
came to organic really trying to ban agent
orange and my concerns about pesticides and
herbicides.
People come to organic for different reasons,
have different paths to, uh, eventually say,
"You know, I wanna be positive, I wanna be
solutions based."
Organic is a solution that we should all support.
Moving the needle, to this day, is still antibiotics
and chemicals and pesticides.
The question that arises ever more frequently
that I wanna now address is, is it more nutritious?
And it's a very difficult question to address.
I was very lucky in my run, I got to know,
uh, Mothers and Others for Livable Planet
which Wendy Gordon and Meryl Streep founded,
got to know them.
At that time, both, for about a year pretty
well and Wendy Gordon decided she wanted to
say that organic was more nutritious, I said,
"Wait a minute."
So she got a new professor on staff in the
early '90s, a woman named Doctor Marion Nestle.
Who is now quite well known in her books and
I would encourage you to log in or get on
her blog, she's a brilliant writer, and says
that, in a matter that someone like me who's
not a scientist, can understand.
And also a woman named Joan Gussow.
So we had several years of meetings in New
York whenever I would come through about addressing
the question of is organic more nutritious?
And the variables seem almost insurmountable
upon, to accumulate those in a manner that
you can say yes or no, and let me just throw
a few out for you to think about.
First of all, America has something called
the standard diet and in a way that's linked
to how much pesticides you can have as residues
on certain-- []. It used to be based on a
180 pound male which became a real issue when
Doctor Philip Landrigan wrote a book called
"Pesticides in the Diets of Infants and Children"
where he came out of his work saying, "Kids
ate applesauce, squash, bananas and you're
saying men eat 6 bananas a year.
Children eat the same amount as men every
week.
This should be, the standard diet should be
based on pesticides that kids get, they're
the most vulnerable."
Then he went on to speculate about, "Well,
what micronutrients are we getting?
Are they getting enough?
How do we manage that when our kids are newborns
and starting out with just four or five, when
they move from mother's milk or formula and
start getting foods."
And I don't believe, I've been on some panels
with him in the past and I don't believe he
ever was able to come to an academic understanding
of how you would measure those kinds of nutrients.
So the standard diet is an issue, pesticide
background contamination is an issue, of course
the soil it's grown in is an issue, the way
the seeds have been bred.
At lunch we talked just a little bit, our
brilliant academic community has, um, not,
through classic breeding practices, actually,
very little recombinant DNA, although they've
begun to embrace that as well, have bred our
seeds for our products now for ease of harvest,
uh, mechanical tornado harvesting.
That, the tomato has to be, all of them in
a thousand acres, has to be about the right
size with thicker skin so the machine can
pick it.
Actually in the last few days they discovered
that in the process of growing these tomatoes,
they also need to look a certain color cause
we tend to buy really orange ones so they
bred in color, and they also need to take
up more water because we all buy everything
by the pound.
So we're actually buying the water that we
subsidize to irrigate it back and, uh, broccoli
or tomato that's taken up a little bit more
water.
Brilliant marketing, academic, Bayh Dole act,
companies want this.
Now you come along and they discovered that
the, uh, in breeding it, literally in the
last few days the sciences have come out that
they discovered that in this quest for the
harvested tomato, they had lost the gene for
taste.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: And that they had just, heck,
where is it?
And they had just discovered where it was
and now they're gonna breed that gene into
the tomato for taste as well.
I started yelling at the computer screen when
I read that story.
It's like, just go out and get heirloom tomatoes,
brothers and sisters, what are you doing trying
to get another silver bullet to shoot another
gene into an agro industrial system that is
largely energy based.
We can't ship those tomatoes around the world
that much longer or import them that much
longer with spikes on energy.
So I think it's a bit meandering here but
soil fertility, biological activity in the
soil breaks down the micronutrients slower
that heirloom seeds pick up faster.
Then it has to be harvested for immediate
deliveries cause we all know that starts to
break down once it's been harvested.
Can organic do that?
Yes, it's clearly doing it.
There are a number of studies out there doing
that but they're citrus specific or, uh, heirloom
variety tomato specific in New England in
the summer or strawberry specific.
Thus, on a podium, I can't yet, in all honesty,
say that organic is more nutritious.
>>Presenter 2: But, as soon as I hear you
say, "They're breeding the plants to do, for
more water uptake," I'm hearing nutrient,
uh, nutrient scarcity, the density is now
diluted, nutrient dilution.
Is that, that must be true.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Um, certainly in the soils,
you know, as the soils break down as it's
all about breeding something will take up
N, nitrogen N, faster and more efficiently.
You have a route that's looking for that fertilizer.
Sorry to put a personality on it but it's
just not gonna take time to break down the
nodule on a cover crop that's left that little
piece nitrogen node on its root to break down
over the winter.
It's not gonna look for it.
It's gonna go right to where the N is in concentration,
that's the fertilizer we put down a couple
weeks ago.
I brought with me and sent over to you which
you can make available.
I did look up, uh, what is it, yeah, here's
the June 29th issue of the journal Science,
um, talked about finding the gene that makes
tomato taste better.
So being published in Science is fantastic,
it's very important point of view but, and
the fact that these publications are covering
these kind of stories is also very new.
Science and Nature is a two premier publications,
they never really covered organic until the,
actually one of the first organic research
stories they ran in Science was in the mid
90s, actually one of the early OFRF grants
was Doctor John Reganold who compared organic
apples, biodynamic apples and conventional
apples for, uh, price, taste, nutrient density
and, um, I think shelf life.
And he found that 4 out of the 5 cases, organic
exceeded that in an academic protocol and
biodynamic won the other one.
And OFRF made those, made those grants.
I'm really proud of that grant.
>>Presenter 2: You have some other historical,
uh, artifacts you brought.
You wanna tell us about that?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Some other goodies.
Sure, Uh,
[Pause]
>>Bob Scowcroft: 19, no wait, 2009 the Journal
of HortScience did a story on the sorry state
of American fruits and veggies.
Basically what they found, again, I can give
the link later on, this was a case of such
a quest for color, taste, harvest ability
that conventional produce tested out for,
I think, 7 to 10 micronutrients, 40 percent
lower than organic.
So it wasn't, depends on which side of the
coin I guess, it wasn't that organic is necessarily
less nutritious, it was that an organic fully
four season biological system was maintaining,
the, um, delicate balance of nutrients in
their fruits and vegetables as compared to
conventional which had really largely abandoned,
um, their breeding program for more of the
commercial marketplace.
[Pause]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Here's a couple
>>Presenter 2: Life magazine?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Life, okay, this is kind
of an ageist here
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: 1970, Life magazine, as far
as I know this is the first cover story about
organic.
Written in 1970, organic comes of age and,
you know, blonde, young actress with her organic.
Those, uh, you don't necessarily have to chuckle
out loud but those of you who remember TV
and ads at the time, I checked out she had
one acting gig.
She was a model on TV for Noxzema shaving
cream where she purred, "Take it off, take
it all off."
And some guy would shave his, um, and she
made so much money that she bought an organic
food store
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: and left acting to be an
organic activist.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Uh, and, uh, it goes on to
show that you see Santa Cruz Farm and Garden
and talk about how organic has come of age
since the '50s.
And I think it's really a phenomenal read.
Since I'm here at Google and I'd, actually
I got the desired response at lunch when I
showed it around, there's also two ads in
here, one for this breathtaking new technological
development, at 200 dollars per, it's something
called a Polaroid camera.
So, when I've showed it in certain places
people like, "Yeah, organic, that's cool,
right?
'70s, but look at that Polaroid camera for
200 dollars.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: breathlessly the newest deal
out there.
But it's important, again, really for what
they talked about USC and crop rotation and
whole grains and nutrition and what USC, I
said USC, UCSC, produced.
I also wanted to show
>>Presenter 2: Well, that's a story.
>>Bob Scowcroft: two other things here, maybe
three I'm, I try to bring something to get
a chuckle.
You never know your audience entirely so don't
feel like you have to go overboard on my last
piece here.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Or, actually, I'll show the
book, too.
In 1979, the last year of the Carter administration,
a couple people said organic's kind of working.
And he tasks a group of scientists and farmers
to come together and write a task force report
on organic and make some recommendations.
If this is real, this is growing, what should
we do to expand organic farming?
And they wrote this report, they made 20 some
odd recommendations and it was published,
um, literally the last few weeks of the Carter
administration, an organic program coordinator
was hired to then implement these recommendations
and he was on staff when the Reagan administration
came in.
Whatever your politics are, John Block was
the Secretary of Ag at the time and under
the 'reduce Government and eliminate waste',
he laid off 500 people as one of his first
day green slip, pink slipped 500 people at
the USDA.
Big press, great, immediately reducing, well,
they rehired 498 of them as consultants.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Cause they needed this staff
but they kept 2 off permanently.
Now, that was Doctor Youngberg and the poor
woman in the secretary pool who happened to
be assigned to his desk to help him, she was
laid off as well.
But then they went further, they ordered all
the copies destroyed, and the, uh, the plates
that printed this also be destroyed.
And I happened to be in Garth's office the
day that order came down and he was distraught,
I mean, this is kind of his life's work.
So, um, seeing myself as a kind of a movie
character and feeling adventurous, uh, I took
20 of these and wrapped them up in brown paper
thinking that, and smuggled them out of USDA
passed security.
And I made a much more of a, I mean, really
I just walked out the door with a bag.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: But it had, I thought I had
the only copies of this document at that time.
One reporter, this is the power of the press,
James Risser from the Des Moine Register,
wrote a story about this and, uh, the uproar
was so strong that, though Garth was never
allowed back in the USDA, this became the
most requested report in the '80s during the
Reagan administration.
Number one, tens and tens of thousands, that's
good news.
>>Presenter 2: And how much of this has been
implemented?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Only 5 of the recommendations
have been fully implemented.
Now, I have to say, um, Deputy Director of
the USDA is Doctor Kathleen Merrigan, she's
a former OFRF board member, she's number two,
she's created and fully implemented, now,
all of these recommendations are now in the
implementation track.
She has a fantastic website called 'Know Your
Farmer, Know Your Food'.
I almost thought about dialing that in.
They had an event today at the White House;
she emailed me this morning saying, "If you
want to link into it, it's about women farmers.
It's how to find local, how to find how your
USDA dollars, farmer's market, hoop houses.
It's a really, really cool program that has
a compass and they just released 2.0 this
morning.
You might think organic is, uh, that the classic
liberal, conservative divide is around organic
and it generally has an image of being a left
or a liberal, uh, phenomenon.
But you'd probably, or maybe not, maybe I'm
wrong but, um, our general assessment is there
are more republican organic farmers than there
is democrat, if you will.
There's a route in organic of conserve, as
in conservatism that is particularly out in
the heartland that these farmers have taken,
the parents, the grandparents and now the
children have taken very seriously.
And, uh, one of the more famous or infamous
depending upon your point of view, it was
a gentleman named Paul Weyrich, passed away
a couple years ago, he founded the Free Congress
Foundation, he wrote a news and commentary
called the Conservative Voice, for many years
he was sort of the conservative voice to what
Norquist is to 'no taxes'.
He was, what he said was conservatism when
and he wrote an amazing column on February
2006, the next conservatism and conservation
where he declared the future of conservatism
was organic family farms and protecting our
soil and managing our water and buying locally.
It's an amazing document.
If we wrote it, another bit of propaganda,
but time and time again, I accept all interviews.
I've been interviewed by, uh, Liv, many times
New York Times AP.
I've also been on the 700 Club, um, [laughter]
you name it, part of my motto is to complete
and total transparency.
I'll ask, answer any question for anybody
at anytime.
And I love bringing this, uh, bring this out.
His last one is, "Think locally, act locally."
This was the Conservative Voice in 2006 and
maybe more than any document we should have
this on all of us whenever debates break out
or the more public presentations.
What's to be against about, Paul Weyrich's
vision of a family farm, the Jeffersonian,
steel of our backbones from buying and keeping
our monies and food and our soil where it
belongs.
It's very important.
And then, though I have others here, two others
and then we'll go to Q and A, wanna do that?
>>Presenter 2: Sure.
>>Bob Scowcroft: In the theme of taking any
interview at any time, let's see is this dated,
yeah; in 2003 I got a call from a reporter
from the National Enquirer.
How many people know the National Enquirer?
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: I see some hands went like
this.
Nobody looked around so you're okay.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: So the National Enquirer
calls and she says she's a reporter and I'm
sure this is a joke, one of my buddies, I
mean, this is the kind of, this is what we
do for fun, is pretend, internally.
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: And she was doing a story,
"Are organic foods worth the cost?"
And, you know, I just wanted to say is this
Joanne?
Is this, come on, you know, ha ha.
I did it once or twice and she got really
irritated and said, "I'm in New York, I'm
on a deadline, I report for the National Enquirer
and I'm doing this story."
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: "Mister Scowcroft, do you
wanna talk or not?"
So I played it straight and she did a long
interview.
She called others and low and behold, she
wrote an incredibly straight story.
All, as any reporter would write.
She went out, checked farmer's markets, she
asked about the rule and the 95 percent, the
100 percent, some other questions, not all
of which went in there and they had photos
of a farmer's market and we ended up talking
for about an hour and a half.
And, you know, I'm not a subscriber and I
didn't quite wanna buy one every week at the
checkout stand for other reasons.
So, um, being, uh, having a sense of humor
I had a contest, internal to the staff and
others, that we wanted to see who would discover
it first cause we have a lot of eyes and ears
out there and we'd give them some kind of
prize.
And it took about 6 weeks before someone outside
of the staff said, "Well, my Grandmother's
uncle was at the barber shop."
It was clear they had bought it themselves
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: but they had about 5 degrees
of separation to the fact that they had gotten
the article and read it and low and behold
I was quoted in the National Enquirer.
This is the range of interest that we have
out, out there and these kinds of stories.
And I thought it was, um, rather phenomenal
that she wanted to do this.
I should add at the end of the phone call,
we went into pesticides and antibiotics, at
the end of the phone call, you know, "Thank
you, Mr. Scowcroft" and she said, "By the
way, um, I really hate you" and it just came
from such a, I said, "What, excuse me?
Did I?"
She said, "Well, no it's not you, it's that
I had take out and it's been delivered while
I've been talking to you and now I don't think
I can eat it."
[Laughter]
>>Bob Scowcroft: And I thought, "Okay, one
person at a time."
You know, one person at a time.
>>Presenter 2: Um, I'll begin with the first
question, this is, there are people who are
saying organic is now so mainstream, I mean,
Doctor Oz is talking about eating organic,
Oprah talks about eating organic.
Walgreens carries it, there are enough disruptive
farmers in California who are saying organics
is so diluted, so it's so mainstream now,
it's not really organic anymore.
Is it, is it?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Uh, absolutely.
It's the law of the land.
If it's not organic, it's a felony.
So you have to meet those regulations.
Now, some of those perspectives come from
a quest for purity.
>>Presenter 2: Yes.
>>Bob Scowcroft: I should back up a little
bit; organic is still a voluntary term.
Nobody's making anyone in this room farm that
way, garden that way, thus, eat that way.
If you choose to buy an organically labeled
product, you have the force of law behind
you and, actually, in the last few years as
they begun to enforce it, several, actually
several people have now gone to jail for violations
of multimillion dollar violations of the certificates
and the rules.
Purity is, uh, why we set up the national
organic standards board.
This is a board that's set up to assess when
a material can be allowed or not be allowed.
Whether a practice should be approved or not
approved.
And it's a passionate debate and some of the
materials that have been allowed generate
intense passion and when the vote comes down
against it, somebody raised their hand and
said, "Well, that's it.
Industrial farming's taken over.
It's not organic anymore."
>>Presenter 2: I hear that a lot.
>>Bob Scowcroft: That's untrue.
Nevertheless, some of the advances and their
ability to become part of the rule are very
slow.
So I, again, as we talked over lunch, uh,
my feeling is that knowing if you have the
time and energy, knowing your farmer, visiting
her farm, his operation, is always, uh, one
of the best ways to go about it.
Particularly if it's in your neighborhood.
I'm, uh, a flexitarian when it comes to the
long push of organic.
We need all the farmers we can get to farm.
We hope to provide the tools to farm organically,
we hope the body of science and knowledge
and the passion to continue continuous improvement,
to take root.
Some are less patient than others to get there.
So, but you're right to know that organic
is embedded in the law.
Transparency is a critical part of that.
So if you wanna tease that out some more that's
fine.
>>Presenter 2: Well, I would but I think there's
some questions.
Yeah, you wanna stand up?
Yeah, I think we can hear you in the room.
Go ahead.
>>male #2: You have to repeat the questions.
>>Presenter 2: I have to repeat, okay.
>>female #1: My question is are there countries
that are doing it better than us and what
lessons we can learn from those countries?
>>Presenter 2: Who does organic better than
we do?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Um, many.
And almost universally because their Governments
have endorsed it, have invested in it and
created action plans to grow it.
There are a number of European countries that
have goals, some of which have already been
met to have 20 percent of their food economy
be certified organic.
Sweden, um, Switzerland, a National University
in Switzerland is an organic university.
One of the people in that quick video, Brian,
Doctor Brian Baker, has been hired out of
a university in New York, he's moved to Geneva
to be the translator of all the European research
out of the, this is the university project
that translates organic research from around
the world into English.
We can't even do that here.
And Brian is now doing it out of, uh, F-I-B-L,
which is the acronym worldwide.
Just, what a concept.
Where is our academic institutions on almost
a simple information gathering?
>>Presenter 2: You were saying at lunch, what's
the top university in this country for organics?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Now a number have organic
engagement programs but in my personal opinion,
and since this is on film I'll be hearing
it from many of them that I didn't name, but
Washington State University is where it's
at.
WSU is phenomenal.
They have organic undergraduate programs,
they have organic online programs, they have
organic masters and PhD programs.
They just received a 5 million dollar grant
to expand, uh, their organic farm.
Not only in its own ability to be state of
the art organic research but they have integrated
the organic, they actually call it the smart
farm, cause the architectural school's gotten
really excited.
The computer, there's an amazing amount of
computer applications, apps, for organic farming
just being developed.
Water hydrology, the water use, soil fertility
and the business school, all now are integrated
into the WSU smart farm program.
And I found it ironic that UC Davis with a
thousand professors in Ag, I'm sorry, Post-Docs,
assistant professors, Ag professors nearby
that WSU comes to Santa Cruz and San Francisco
to raise money for their organic farm in Washington
when Davis has five or six organic researchers
out of that thousand.
>>Presenter 2: Yes?
>>male #3: Hi, um, I find that the terminology
when it comes to animal friendly agriculture
practices and, you know, and organic animal
products gets a little confusing.
Like, for me, it's really important to have
eggs for like chicken that are able to, like,
graze a pasture and stuff like that.
And, you know, now when you go to the farmer's
markets they have farms that advertise sort
of pastured eggs or whatever.
But I'm, I mean, I find that I don't really
know exactly what that means and it's not
really breaking the rule, right, I mean, so
I guess I'm wondering whether there is any
progress being made about putting some teeth,
some regulatory teeth behind sort of animal
agriculture or terminology and things like
that?
>>Presenter 2: Regulations and terminology
around pastured eggs etcetera.
>>Bob Scowcroft: You know, the success of
the organic label, it is the only competitive
conventional egg and it is extremely different,
profoundly different.
It's now trying to be modeled by many other
ecolabels.
The flip side of that is that many other ecolabels
really don't wanna go through 20 years of
legislative action, regulatory formatting
or framework, I call it sort of the natural
regulatory spaghetti thrown against the wall.
I'm happy, animal free pasture, no drugs,
sometimes sprayed, I mean, it's just everything
is out there and, uh, particularly in animal
welfare issues right now.
It's really, to the extent possible, getting
a tour, getting to a location, getting to
a farmer or rancher or talking to them in
the farmer's markets with, uh, again, I don't
know how close you follow this but, uh, the
Humane Society had a revolutionary breakthrough
50 years coming, has made an agreement with
the Ag producers association to have these
larger cages, um, we go from a foot to 5 feet.
They can, chickens can turn around now.
This is the grand bargain that we've made
and it's not in the Farm Bill.
The powers that be struck it out and the powers
that be are the pork producers.
"My God, if they let chickens turn around
then hogs will have to get out of their crates."
If you really wanna be clinically depressed
on animal production look at a conventional
hog operation.
>>male #3: Yeah, you know, I actually do that.
You know, I do, I've been to like 2 particular
farms in this area that I know exactly how
they treat their chickens and those are the
only farms that I'll buy from.
But I mean, I think, for, in order for this
sort of to drop, you know, drive sort of greater
adoption of these animal-friendly practices.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Well, many of the animal
welfare groups are trying but right now the
heads of Ag committees won't even hold hearings.
They won't even, I mean, the congressman from
Oklahoma who's an extremely conservative individual
and remarkably pro agro industrial systems
approach, passed the Farm Bill, can't even
get Boehner to put it on the floor of the
House.
That's the stranglehold that the industrial
farming system right now has.
If it goes on before the house then there's,
um, what many people are calling a Monsanto
amendment which waives all the regulations
around genetic engineering and requires the
USDA to approve anything within one year of
application without health and safety testing.
So one amendment got in of 70 or 80, I think,
in the Farm Bill so it's just too, that's
where the consumer power, that's particularly
impressed with an entity like Google and the
operation you have here 'cause you are, in
fact, leveraging forces by orders of magnitude
as a group more than you would ever guess.
You have no, I mean, maybe you kind of hear
it or maybe it's kind of sort of the road
now, the norm.
You have no idea what you're buying power
can do
[Sneezing in audience ]
>>Bob Scowcroft: as far as leveraging change.
Well, there's questions everywhere.
>>male #4: Can you talk a little bit more
about the cost dynamic?
You've mentioned it a few times that there's,
there's a, there's economies of scale yet
to capture.
What are the specifics there and how do you
balance that against the other comments you've
made around knowing your farmer and how do
you know your farmers and keep your produce
local when things start to grow and stuff
like that.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Uh, the complexity of the
marketplace, you can get to a certain scale
and go to 7 farmer's markets and you and maybe
1 or 2 workers harvest that and bring it direct
to market.
You're paying the farmer pretty much the entire
cost for that.
But that's still some fruits and vegetables,
once you start getting into cold storage,
there's a little bit more as a middle person
there.
Once you get into larger trucks or hydro coolers
or ice machines that broccoli has to go on
ice just about in the field, a little bit
more cost there.
Now you start to look at the scale as I have
an ice machine maybe I should grow a lot more
broccoli and hire 5 workers and sell it into
a regional chain.
Cost might go down at a certain point but
now you wanna grow something difficult, trial
and error, you've gotta grow it out several
years to see whether you can grow okra or,
and we're just talking fruits and vegetables,
um, if you're inter, I'm sorry, just vegetables,
tree fruit, do I wanna put 5 years of apple
varieties when, into my farm when apples might
go out of vogue and raspberries.
Anyone that's been down in the Watsonville,
Salinas area knows that, I mean, even when
I moved there in the '80s, apple trees were
everywhere, there's 1 or 2 apple growers left
because raspberries, raspberries, raspberries,
raspberries.
So now, apple growers, they have harvesters
that come through, they have an intense season,
they can put it into storage for 3 or 4 months.
Completely different infrastructure for that
land and they have equipment, cost up front,
loans, crop insurance, certain size,HACCP,
food safety issues now regulatory over, overlays
that you have to follow.
So, scaling up and commodity specific and
your business plan and your marketing initiatives,
all play a role in that dynamic and then when
you get into meat products, for example, there
was a fantastic hog farmer, almost have their
name, just wait, in Watsonville and we all
went, "Finally, we can eat pulled pork.
We can eat bacon from the farmer's market."
Those of us that eat meat and that farmer
couldn't make it, they ended up losing their
money for one reason, their only slaughter
facility was down in Los Angeles area and
it was so large that it couldn't even take
their 10 hogs every 2 weeks make, they couldn't
cleanup, never mind that it was natural or
organic.
So, California is in desperate need of what's
called a mobile slaughter unit that can actually
go to the farm and slaughter specific to the
five, you know, name your meat products and
some of the dairy issues and some of the cheese
making issues.
So it becomes very complex very quickly relative
to what stream of commerce you wanna go into.
One of the more recent responses to that are
certain aggregators or co-ops where a number
of veg growers are going together and starting
to aggregate and using one dock and one cooling
system or a grower that had a cooling system
is beginning to see another stream of income
cooling other very small grower's product.
It might be one pallet, it might be 3 pallets,
drive up literally with your pickup truck
with 20 flats of strawberries and they'll
cool it for a couple of days so then you can
move it out when it's ready.
I don't know if that's helpful but it's just
the complexities
>>male #4: Yeah, it just seems like there's
a huge need for, like you said, shared infrastructure
in the middle tier of the producer and buyer
and then a lot of these organic people have
it incredibly difficult, like I read the Omnivore's
Dilemma and they talk about how organic first
started it was not just about revolutionizing
how food was produced but also how it was
distributed and what people ate.
And it seems like, at least sitting in the
sort of Shangri La of San Francisco, the piece
of that that's still has a lot of development
to do is the distribution piece in the middle
cause these small farms have such a challenge
getting their food to market.
>>Bob Scowcroft: I would actually say it has
been revolutionized even since Michael wrote
that but it is in certain regional locations.
There's an amazing co-op up in Eugene in Portland
called Organically Grown.
It was founded by organic farmers.
It now represents several hundred organic
farmers.
It's an ESOP, they have shares, they have
bonus plans, employee stock, 140 of the 200
employees own this company now and they have
built the entire infrastructure by and for.
They go to restaurants, wholesalers, they
may serve some of the entities up there, people
at lunch seemed to know.
But what we're still, this is still really
essentially outside those 7 buyers I brought
up before.
The 4 supermarkets and the 3 box stores.
>>male #4: [inaudible]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Well, my feeling is that
to get it to 50 percent, those 7 buyers bring
it to an economic strata that we can't reach,
commodities of which can work in that format
for a period of time in the future and my
quip to the Nation, the Nation did a story
about it and I got in a little bit of trouble
saying, "Well, the good news is those pesticides
are not being used on 100 thousand acres,
because of scale it won't go into that, but
our response was like [indistinct], now we
need to set up a peach tasting stand at the
entrance to those box stores and let them
know what a real peach just harvested tastes
like.
Then those people can come to the farmer's
market.
If you go to some of the intense markets in
Oakland, you'll see the organic tables have
longer lines than the conventional.
As a matter of fact, very important survey
done for years if not decades by the Grower
magazine, fresh produce the packer, most conventional
publication out there has consistently shown
that the lower the economic strata, the greater
the desire for organic products.
Completely countered the image that you see
some of these NGOS that are opposing organic
want, it's an elite food.
I mean, we certainly have not done a good
job, I can think of any number of video examples
of the most amazing superstar that only eats
organic that reinforces the elite image but
the fact of the matter is that when given
the possibility and the opportunity that all
economic strategists specifically the lower
ones which use organic consistently shown
in the conventional publication.
>>male #5: [Indistinct]
>>Bob Scowcroft: I love that question.
>>male #5: So I was wondering if you could
talk to the science?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Sure.
Well, there's a couple of things.
First of all, where are, where does it say
the US to feed the world?
We certainly feed corn and soy beans to feed
stations around the world but, um first, secondly
we already produce something like 1.4, um,
1.4, one and half times more food than the
earth consumes currently.
The waste, war and storage and transportation
eliminate a phenomenal amount of that food.
And, uh, my passion is to declare that we
should be feeding the world information rather
than somehow assuming that we are industrializing
and exploiting our soil to move, uh, feed
products in competition to Brazil or Russia
and China to meet operations elsewhere.
>>male #5: So from a food system perspective
if you wanted to take an international [indistinct]
>>Bob Scowcroft: Absolutely, the FAO has published
a number of papers recently showing, that's
an entity of the UN and I can't pull the name
up right now.
>>Presenter 2: Food and Agriculture Organization.
>>Bob Scowcroft: And there's a rocket, no
not rocket, well there's one person that's
particularly been overseeing a lot of these
peer reviewed research reports showing now
that organic fields are better than conventional
and a number of the African nations that,
particularly women, owned and run, small family
farms are producing a significantly better
yield and crop rotation systems and local
cover crop, compost, green manure crops and
that if we are serious about, really serious
about feeding the world we should be cooperatively
developing research stations and information
stations not genetically engineered products
that require fertilizer and chemicals.
Just exporting the problems that were showing
up, having shown up here.
>>Presenter 2: Last question.
>>male #6: So, one issue you haven't mentioned
at all, I'm curious to hear your thoughts
on the community garden.
I have the good fortune of being married to
woman who has a passion for it.
We have all manner of [indistinct] and peppers
[indistinct] elsewhere.
Does this have any impact on scale or is just
a hobby for --
>>Presenter 2: Can gardening impact, can mini
farming as John Jeavons calls it, impact our
food supply?
>>Bob Scowcroft: I think it could.
Some very intriguing initial papers are starting
to come out about community gardens, actual
just yields and nutrient delivery among some
of these gardens but by far, the more important
component of gardening is the actual individual
act of growing your own food and understanding
what it takes and particularly in community
gardens working with others building a community
around a food and breaking bread and meal
culture.
We don't really have that in the US.
If you go to Italy or some of these other,
I came home the other day and there was a
bag of plums on my front doorstep and nobody
even put a note on it and they were incredible
and I knew they came from my street or somewhere
and then just yesterday somebody shouted out,
you know, "I got plums up the wazoo and I
just went to every house and dropped them.
I hope they were great!"
And it was a moving, it was a moment.
It was great.
I'm happy to eat these plums in my cereal
every morning.
I have a very special Bartlett pear tree in
my backyard and I've been doing the same thing,
dropping them off cause they all have to go
pretty much come off in the next 2 weeks.
So I think those acts of both just the personal,
it came from my garden, the salad or the fruit
tree.
I really want a Meyer lemon tree; I killed
my last lemon plant.
I was working too hard.
I think the garden movement is very important
and the last thing I'd say is the gardeners
by and large are gonna save us all because
they're growing out heirloom seeds and exchanging
seeds and saving seeds and trading seeds where
the new organic seed movement and seed alliance
and seed savers are coming from, by and large,
gardeners.
If it wasn't for the gardeners that have done
this the last 30 years.
>>Presenter 2: It's something to do with,
to take of suburban sprawl is to start growing
food on it, right?
>>Bob Scowcroft: Now, Detroit has a food plan,
it's very contrev, someone wants to industrialize
that but basically Detroit has an actual plan
and it's beginning to take some of these blocks
and turn it back to farming and the larger
community agricultural garden stations to
feed the community around it.
And that is a mayor initiative supported by
Whole Foods and a number of, you know, philanthropic
entities.
I should say one more thing, just to close,
can I do that?
>>Presenter 2: Sure, yes, please, your book.
Well, the book you're in.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Yeah, it's not mine.
One of the things that I'm at the very early
stages, and I'm saying this for the record,
I guess people are gonna have to start holding
me to it but I'm gonna write a book, the people's
history of organic . We've got 35 years of
these little, I brought other goodies like
in Russian, in St. Petersburg Russia, a sale
of organic cranberries.
So if you're really short here in the US you
can go over to St. Petersburg, buy organic
cranberries.
But, I'm 61, many of us have been working
on this for 30, 40 years, are retiring or
disengaging entirely, I'm not I'm just doing
things in a different way now.
But I think capturing our history is really
important so I got an idea years ago, I was
looking for revolutionary librarians, which
a particular audience though that's was really
funny, revolutionary librarians.
But, actually, 2 came up to me afterwards
and said, "We are revolutionary librarians."
And I said, "Well, what I want you to do is
an oral history of the 20 people that started
organic in California" Well, a few have passed
away, others are in their 70s, some of us
are in a late 50s, 60s.
We need to capture this.
And low and behold they ended up with 52 oral
histories at UC Santa Cruz's McHenry Library,
all downloadable mp3's you can listen ad nauseum
for hours at us talking away and then it got,
within the library system they were so excited
about at UC Press, said let's make a book
out of it.
And they tasked the librarians to find the
best and put it in order and get about 15,
18 pages of each one in print and this just
came out, it's called "Cultivating a Movement"
and it's, I found it, I'm learning things
about my friends that I didn't know.
Jim Cochran the great strawberry grower and
UFW supporter started the daycare, as an assistant
in a daycare program.
But we should all, in almost every menu, be
capturing our oral history now.
And so I'm going around the country to other
places and I'm a trustee on a foundation so
I'm actually, I think, working with other
foundations.
I think there's some funding now to, cause
this is mostly all local.
What happened in New England, what happened
in Oklahoma, what happened in Wisconsin and
Washington is, in a way, an indigenous to
the place.
But, the students job will be to study this
and to find the common themes.
But, "Cultivating a Movement" is a pretty
cool read and you will recognize some of the
farmers in there if you go take a look on
the web about it.
It can be purchased through UCSC, I didn't
bring it, Irene is really the hero that did
this book.
I have a chapter in here, as well.
Amazon, I guess, has it too.
>>Presenter 2: Well, we're gonna look for
your, your memoirs.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Well, yeah, the people's
history of organic has a couple of PG-13 stories
about it too.
Some great scandals and the gathering of the
tribe of organic activists both young and
old is at Asilomar Conference Center every
January.
It's 32 years running, I've been to all but
3 and they're from 80 years old to 8.
It's a great conference .And, of course, that's
where we reconnected last January that led
to me coming here today.
>>Presenter 2: Thank you so much.
>>Bob Scowcroft: Thank you very much for coming.
[Applause]